if everybody wins no one won no one won
but also no parent gets to have the
conversation like oh you lost and this
is okay or no parent gets to have that
conversation like oh you won don't be a
sore winner yeah well the the
conversation is oh you lost but that
doesn't mean you're a loser right right
that's the important conversation no
parent but that conversation's not even
happening not if you're not if you don't
have the opportunity to lose right so
parents aren't there's no reprimanding
from the parents there's no connection
there with like um you know if
everybody's a winner then there's no you
you don't need your parent to you know
move you back into a comfortable space
you know when you get off you know you
don't get to tell your son oh hell
what's a loss to a great kid like you
yeah you know it's like and it's
something like that next game yeah for
it yeah there's no like you put your
your arm around your son's neck after
he's lost and he feels that it's a good
game man good game and that or you say
look uh you know that looked a little
rough anything you think you could do
better next time yeah what can we do
what can we do better now yeah let's get
we'll do we'll try it tomorrow yeah yeah
but that kind of stuff those moments I
feel like are the moments that build
especially young men and live inside of
them first so one of the things that's
that I find quite painful is all these
people that I'm encountering it's
obvious that no one has ever encouraged
them yeah and I mean encouraged
technically no one has attempted to
instill courage into them yes and to say
look man you're worthwhile you're
worthwhile you're worthwhile no there's
something in you that could develop into
something great that's sort of like the
right definition of worthwhile it's not
like you're okay the way you are it's
like no you're not right what and why
would I ever say that because what okay
you're just fine well great you might as
well just like take take Ambien and
become unconscious because you've got
nothing else to do yeah it's like no
there's plenty for you to do to put
yourself together but you're the sort of
person who could do it you could put
yourself together you could be more than
you are and you should be because
otherwise the world degenerates into
hell yeah which is exactly what happens
it's like and it's it's so sad in some
sense for me to see how little
encouragement people actually need
because there's lots of people coming to
talk to me and they say well you know I
haven't had a father there was no male
influence in my life or no one's ever I
no one's ever well that's basically it
they haven't had that kind of
encouraging influence and so no one's
ever said these things to them and so
someone says something to them they go
oh really that's the possibility and
then they go out and like fix things it
didn't take much
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one